[Musica]
cosa state pensando guardandomi sono
tanti pregiudizi legate all'aspetto
anche quello che avrà emesso per venire
qua poteva essere giudicato da
pregiudizi con una gonna troppo corta
era stato un esibizionista con un seno
troppo esposto una poco di buono
e se poi avesse messo un tacco un anti
femminista e se fosse venuta in tuta beh
ma troppo trasandata ai vertiti non
definiscono che siamo così come il peso
non determina il nostro valore
eppure quante volte questi pensieri
hanno condizionato la nostra vita
personalmente un passato la vita a
combattere il mio corpo perché troppo
tanto rispetto agli standard della
società come se serenità fosse collegata
ad un peso come se chi ha un corpo
ideale giudicato bello perfetto come
magari attori attrici fosse immune da
quei malesseri dalla depressione che può
portare anche alla morte
il punto è che l'ossessione per
l'aspetto fisico è una trappola
sempre in qualunque taglia questo
argomento riguarda tutti a prescindere
dal genere ma utilizzerò il femminile
perché voglio arrivare soprattutto alle
donne che per troppo tempo non hanno
avuto voce
quante volte ci siamo sentite inadeguate
non abbastanza
proprio per una nostra caratteristica
fisica
la ragazzina quando mi mettevo la crema
e sentivo la mia pelle sotto alle mani
provavo disgusto la stringeva questa si
faceva a bucchi la cellulite mi guardava
come sa dirmi non me ne andrò mai
ed è tutta colpa tua e io pensavo non
merito niente non merito amore non
riesco neanche ad avere il controllo su
me stessa spoiler le mie cose non sono
cambiate
e cambiato il mio approccio alle cose
poi a 18 anni ho iniziato a fare la
modella curvi e ho pensato a finalmente
ho trovato il mio posto mi sarei sentita
una
nessuno avrebbe mai più detto frasi come
bel viso se solo perderci un po di peso
non è andata così anche quella
esperienza mi ha aiutato a capire che
non esiste qualcosa o qualcuno che può
darti autostima
siamo solo noi passo dopo passo a poter
imparare a conoscerci e darsela è facile
no
non è facile io stessa molte volte mi
son sentito una fallita proprio perché
cercavo di volermi più bene ma non ci
riuscivo
erano per quello alle sfilate perché
avevo quei due centimetri di bacino in
più era per il fidanzato del tempo che
mi diceva guarda da quando hai preso
dieci chili e non sono più attratto da
te tutto costantemente mi faceva capire
che per essere accettabile dovevo essere
più magra stavo dicendo che cercavo di
prendermi cura di me ma a pensarci bene
lo faceva sempre con un atteggiamento
punitivo e l'atteggiamento è qualcosa da
non sottovalutare perché la stessa
azione fatta in un modo o in un altro
può portare con sé un energia totalmente
differente fare sport nutrirci vestirci
metterci una crema può essere fatto con
molto odio nei nostri confronti volendo
eliminare qualcosa volendo nasconderci
oppure può essere fatto lasciando andare
questa negatività dandoci cura ed amore
e vi assicuro che l'energia che arriva
da lì non arrivano altri modi
adesso ho imparato che non esistono
imperfezioni ma solo caratteristiche
soprattutto in un corpo umano ma prima
mi combattevo e quando fai una guerra
tra te e te
comunque vada tu perdi
pensiamo anche a come siamo abituati a
pensare che magrezza corrisponda a
bellezza e che bellezza corrisponda
felicità questa è una menzogna
personalmente ho passato tutta la vita
sa perdere e prendere peso
sono arrivata persino ad ammalarmi di
bulimia perché pensavo fosse l'unico
modo rimasto per cercare di raggiungere
quel peso ideale minimo di cui tutti
parlavano così bene sembrava che avrebbe
portato serenità anche una volta
raggiunto non è ha portato nemmeno un
briciolo questo perché appunto come ho
detto poco fa magrezza non corrisponde a
bellezza e bellezza non corrisponde a
felicità questa è una delle cose più
fasulle e pericolose che ci ha trasmesso
la cultura della dieta che ci vuole
annichilire all'idea che solo da magri
avremo un certo valore così distraendoci
dal cercare le nostre reali competenze
le nostre capacità distraendoci persino
dal cercare il nostro vero benessere
psicofisico
pensiamo anche a quante volte al
complimento ma come stai bene se
dimagrita
abbiamo risposto con un grazie più
iniziato a pensare che non fosse più un
complimento da un po di tempo era
proprio durante una dieta molto drastica
dove oltre che a deperire stavo
prendendo anche gioia vitale che mi
dicevo ma come io io in questo momento
non mi vedo bella
sono triste ossessionata impaurita dal
cibo io io non sono felice mi chiedo
allora ma che cos'è la bellezza
perché per me è qualcosa che va al di là
delle mode passeggere di caratteristiche
che vanno più o meno di moda è
un'energia che va oltre tempo spazio
forme colori e armonia
eppure ci fanno credere costantemente
che sono con certe caratteristiche
fisiche saremmo adeguati perché lo fanno
e bei ragazzi ma perché gli fa comodo
stimolare il senso di inadeguatezza e
uno dei più facili metodi di vendita
quindi gli facciamoci caso se lo stanno
utilizzando con noi e rispondiamo con un
bel no grazie ho imparato a stare bene
con me la diffusione mediatica di diete
restrittive di un'idea di corpo perfetto
sono andati di pari passo al momento
costante di disturbi alimentari e questa
è un'altra cosa che dovrebbe un attimo
far preoccupare
addirittura sono proprio le diete
restrittive ad essere la prima causa di
disturbi alimentari pensiamo che le
statistiche dicono che su cento persone
10 stanno passando o hanno passato un
disturbo alimentare l'età dell'anoressia
è diminuita agli 89 anni
questa cosa è allarmante sono nate nuove
forme di ossessioni come quella al
mangiar sano che mi direte ma ma questo
fa bene fa bene finché c'è equilibrio
perché quando diventa un'ossessione
anch'essa è reputato il disturbo
alimentare e l'obesità poi l'obesità
continua a crescere ma sembra che alla
fine l'unica cosa ci continuino a dire è
vecchio di la bocca non mangiare più e
vedrai che dimagrisci manca ancora
totalmente un'educazione alimentare un
educazione emotiva che ci aiuti a
gestire le nostre emozioni a conoscerle
e questa è una cosa che mi fa veramente
arrabbiare perché ad oggi la grasso
fobia e ovunque grasso fobia è la paura
di ingrassare ma non solo
e anche quel sentirsi in diritto anche
senza rendercene conto di giudicare le
persone grasse come pigre senza forza di
volontà
in un certo senso inferiori noi dobbiamo
imparare a riconoscere il body gaming la
grasso fobia la diet caldo per dirgli
no per non assecondarli uno dei modi più
belli in cui lo faccio è tramite la boni
positiv catwalk l'associazione no profit
decorato con il mio compagno per dire
noi pregiudizi siamo in centinaia che ci
raduniamo in piazze e diciamo
spogliamoci dai pregiudizi uomini e
donne di ogni età tagliani a
orientamento sessuale genere eventuali
deficit
siamo tutti esseri umani è un essere
umano non può essere catalogato dalla
sue caratteristiche
il rispetto deve essere a prescindere da
s
mi direte ma che belle parole però come
facciamo ad imparare ad apprezzare il
nostro corpo soprattutto se l'abbiamo
odiato per tanto tempo
ok vi do alcuni esercizi che a me sono
stati utili
il primo l'ho inventato proprio per
rispondere a questa domanda
immaginiamo un gattino un cucciolotto
maltrattato bisognoso di amore e di cure
non ci viene voglia di dargliele
a questo cucciolotto beh poi il
cucciolotto sei tu
siamo noi ci siamo fatti male per tanto
tempo e adesso abbiamo bisogno di
rimettersi in forze di darci cure
il secondo esercizio è un po più
complicato dobbiamo immaginarci in un
altro corpo sesso di un uomo di una
donna un corpo più atletico più formoso
una persona con disabilità a me molto
utile perché mi fa pensare che se
l'anima sarà serena sarà serena in ogni
corpo
ora torniamo al nostro corpo e pensiamo
cosa posso fare io adesso con le mie
caratteristiche con il mio essere per
essere sereno e magari per rendere
sereno qualcun altro il terzo esercizio
non l'ho inventato io ma è qualcosa che
mi ha squarciato il petto è lo propone
la preghiera del popolo di umano
qui se avete la possibilità
posizionatevi davanti a uno specchio
se non va bene anche il cellulare
guardatevi negli occhi e cercate l'anima
ora dedicatevi queste parole grazie
scusa perdonami
ti amo la prima volta che ho fatto
questo esercizio fra scoppiata a
piangere perché io in quello specchio
avevo sempre cercato un immagine che non
era quella del mio corpo ma non avevo
mai cercato la mia anima
ok questi sono alcuni esercizi che
possono aiutarci a stare meglio con noi
stessi ma ricordiamoci che abbiamo un
compito trasmettere questa
consapevolezza anche agli altri
accogliersi accettarsi non significa mai
arrendersi anzi è l'energia che ci
permette poi di fare tutto il nostro
corpo non definisce che siamo
lasciamo che dalle ferite entry la luce
noi siamo luce grazie